hello and welcome to the spooky science
show and yes i mean spooky because it is
the halloween special this week so we
are talking about zombie cells otherwise
known as senescent cells and there is
not much to be scared about well maybe
there is because we will be discussing a
new study work done by a friend and
former colleague of mine who has shown a
novel approach for the clearance of
senescent cells
so
let's start with the zombie cells well
senescent cells but why are they called
zombies
well zombies are mythical dead people
who have returned to life as a walking
corpse and well they don't look in the
best of health
and i suppose similar features could be
described for a senescent cell these are
cells that aren't doing too well as at
some point earlier in their life they
were exposed to some stressful
situations whether that's the
introduction of dna damage oxidative
stress
over-replication or other stressors that
were just too much for the cell to
handle
but instead of dying instead the cells
stop dividing they enter a so-called
cell cycle arrest
and they don't lie dormant
in fact many senescent cells acquire the
ability to produce and secrete a variety
of factors into their surrounding
environment
this is termed the senescence associated
security phenotype
so like zombie cells they look a bit
dead but they're still active
so some of these factors are
inflammatory components that are thought
to be able to bring in immune cells to
get rid of the senescent cells as well
as other factors are involved in
remodeling the surrounding tissue
environment to help with repair
however it is thought that if the cells
are not eventually cleared and they keep
secreting these factors
over time they could cause chronic
inflammation and have deleterious
pro-aging effects
indeed senescent cells have been shown
to accumulate in different tissues with
age such as the liver skin lung and the
brain
moreover celesten cells are thought to
maybe play a role in different
age-associated diseases such as diabetes
alzheimer's parkinson's disease
arthritis atherosclerosis and obesity
scary stuff
but that is about as scary as it will
get because there is a lot of work
investigating alternative ways of being
able to clear these cells from the body
which could help alleviate symptoms of
different age-associated diseases or
potentially aging itself
if you're interested in this area of
research then one term you have very
likely come across is synolytics
this refers to a group of drugs that
selectively kill senescent cells
for example the drug combination of the
satinib and quercetin are thought to
have this potential and improved
physical function and increased lifespan
in old mice
another proposed analytic i've discussed
on this channel is visiting however
despite some of these analytics now in
or entering human clinical trials there
are some concerns over the translational
potential as many are repurposed
chemotherapeutic drugs and they may not
be specific to senescent cells in terms
of the cell death
and also probably have unknown impacts
on healthy cells
what would be most ideal is to find
mechanisms that are more specific
this may be more beneficial but
importantly would enable a more thorough
analysis of the efficacy of the approach
since in the case of most studies the
only difference is the killing of
senescent cells without any potential
background effects of the synalytic
drugs and healthy cells
so how can we improve specificity
well some of you may remember some
research i explained last year and some
earlier this year
one strategy exploits the fact that
senescent cells typically express a
protein called beta galactosidase the
activity of this protein is often used
to stain for senescent cells
but it's also been shown that toxic
nanoparticles
can be activated only in the presence of
this protein
another approach involved the use of car
t cells i'm not going to fully explain
how that concept works here
but effectively they exploited the
presence of a protein expressed on the
surface of the senescent cells to
activate immune cells to clear just the
cells with this protein being expressed
this last strategy though is quite
expensive
and there's still a lot of interest in
finding more strategies to see what
might be most effective and for what
caesars
and the reason for that is because
senescent cells are very heterogeneous
they are found in different locations
and becomes senescent by different ways
so one strategy might be effective for
one population of senescent cells and
not another
anyway all this brings me on to the
recent publication targeted clearance of
senescent cells using an antibody drug
conjugate against a specific membrane
marker
i'll start with the last two words first
membrane marker so again as i just
explained with these car t cells in this
paper they exploit the surface of
senescent cells
so proteins present in this membrane
that aren't found as frequently in
healthy cells
here they decided to use the protein b2m
as a membrane marker
i asked marta the lead author why they
chose this target and while b2m was
already characterized by the lab and the
expression of btm and their model was
much higher in the senescent cells than
growing non-tenacion cells
and also because it's on the surface
they could target these senescent cells
with an antibody that specifically
recognizes this protein
we'll discuss later on why maybe b2m
isn't a very good marker but for now
let's look at the novel approach to kill
senescent cells
so the title of the paper refers to
antibody drug conjugates simply an
antibody that also has a cytotoxic drug
attached the drug is toxic to cells that
it enters the premise behind this
approach is that the drug is inactive
until it enters the cell
and to enter the cell it first needs to
bind to the surface of the cell
and so this antibody drug conjugate
approach has already been applied to
cancer treatment with many undergoing
clinical trials but this is the first
time it's been tested against senescent
cells
so does it work
well they tested the b2m antibody drug
conjugate against different types of
senescent cells that became senescent
after overexpressing high amounts of the
proteins p53 p21 or p16 which are all
important proteins and senescence
they then examined cell viability to see
what happened when the cells were
treated with the b2m antibody drug
conjugate or a control
antibody drug conjugates
and a control antibody drug conjugate
that shouldn't recognize the senescent
cells or the healthy cells
so the results are best summarized in
these two graphs here the one on the
left shows it for the p53 induced
senescent cells and the one on the right
shows for the p16 induced senescent
cells
control here means the cells were
growing while senescent means well the
cells were senescent
then the first bar shows the control
antibody drug conjugate and then the
second bar is showing it for the b2m
antibody drug conjugates
cool
so what we can see is that the p-33
induced senescent cells showed a reduced
viability when treated with this b2m
antibody drug conjugate
whilst the p16 senescent cells did not
they also further validated this b2m
antibody drug conjugate in another cell
line that was seen in senescent cells
that also depend on p53 activity
but ultimately what this data supports
is that antibody based targeted
synalytics have significant cytotoxic
effects
here they show it works in cells that
have entered tenescent as a result of
activation of the p53 pathway suggesting
that this approach can be both specific
and efficient
but the story does not end there in fact
this work is very exciting but there are
some very important tests and further
work that need to be done which i will
discuss now
firstly we need to talk about b2m
whilst it was an effective specific
target for the cell line they studied in
this paper
in fact marta told me herself it's
actually a terrible marker for senescent
cells
this is because it is expressed in other
tissues in the body
and it's unlikely to give specificity
only to use senescent cells
but this isn't a major problem because
the way that these antibody drug
conjugates work is a bit like lego
bricks if we don't like the beauty web
antibody we can break it off and swap it
for another antibody
one may be more specific for a subset of
senescent cells
but this would require more
experimentation to identify what an
effective target would be
secondly so far the experiments have
only been conducted in cell lines so
cells growing on dishes
it would be important to test this
approach in mouse models before any
human trials could be conducted
and before any steps are taken in human
trials it would be interesting to look
at studies in mice and compare it to the
results of current analytics
as would this approach also have
improvements in physical function with
age
so whilst there are limitations with the
study as a proof of principle this is
definitely a promising approach with
therapeutic potential if other senescent
membrane markers are used especially
since antibody drug conjugates have good
translational potential for human
therapies
so with that i hope you enjoyed the
spooky special thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening